how do you do that at 39 years of age wow look
at that gaping net until that [Music] stretching
after short-handed as a step has helped the
m to come save rewood got over to deny nestic
who is bidding for a shorthanded game time
goal backand attempt and Wedgewood does a
great job look at this look from our crew it's
right off the toe maybe the most important save
of the game turns tried to shot here's an open
and a great save FY robonino oh man how do you
do that at 39 years of age wow look at that
gaping net until that stretch fantastic save
by Mark Andre flurry all that [Applause]
[Music] net to the line again another shot
tip rebound bton made a marvelous save on
OK Conor on the rebound what a save there
boy Jordan Bennington looking great here
early in this first period but man what a
save Kyle grandlin has it now throws it across and
a save hill and cut it a hill lost his stick in
the process sharks only one shot away from making
it really interesting as there's the save by Hill
you can see the tow of his skate light makes
the stop s Jose's had a couple of looks said
gold Knights have carried the majority of the
play but Aiden Hill credit to him staying sharp
working his way in drags holds oh did you see that
brilliant stop off the hottest goal scorer in the
NHL look at Matthew's reaction knew he didn't
quite get it high enough but what acrobatic
save by Corpus Alo to get the glove out there
two onone early it's the red hot Reinhardt our
Rodriguez what a save by Blackwood right off the
Hop he gets on it what a save we talked about it
in the open the athleticism of Blackwood you're
seeing it there Cyro and hold passes big save by
Johanson and he's got it what a stop by yonas
Johanson again Jordan kyou creating dishes off
and Brandon sad is [Music] robbed spin by
Nathan McKinnon all the way across what a
sto a cour he had and quit F thein have
the chance another 10 Bell stop by Joey
dor CR Mel walks it in right in front oh Allan
One Stop rebound available Jake Allen save of
the night and then mv's on the doorstep what
a great save by Jake Allen he had to have that
in the puck battle look out fer space cutting
in and Allan SS with it another stop djie the
followup Rob by Allen he's made some good ones
tonight but that one on DJI was the best they're
down to 2 minutes 28 remaining trailing by two
but it could have been worse if not for Jake
Allen at 341 another shot wide open Martin
scrawling on that one and fabry nearly buried
it and there's the save that Martin made on fabry
just moments ago with the flat paddle of the goal
stick here's McKinnon looks to slide it across
broken up by Smith they Sav by V battle for the
puck Devils knock it into the corner with
unbelievable opportunity oh and a right P
saved by vanich bu and a beauty wow oh good
is that wow what a save M coming the other
way right to the front Schmid Den I Peretti with
a p sa left to right great read by the net minder
away from his Swedish countrymen SL pass here
GL save lingren Dynamite on tley well tooi is
a gunslinger he has eight goals on the season
he doesn't miss too many of them because of
his unbelievable release Rossy on a two onone the
return passing the back hand stop by Levi what a
save oh my Levi keeps this in a one-1 game just
get a piece of it with Pat glove and deflect it
up and over comes out of the zone duain is in
trying to pull it to the front duain oh with a
stop Thea right P Beauty oh beauty is right but
how about the move by duain undresses him but
the right toe of AA Stones him unbelievable
in the corner walk blust it out in front and
Carlson is stopped by Arison what a save by Sam
Arison and the youngster had a chance to get his
team within one but Arison had other ideas what a
save here by Arison two on one B P it across stop
by wall big save there Marner sails out to try
to get the puck has does Austin Matthews quick
two onone and onetime gets it up over the pad
but rolled there with the glove HS it all the
way across the BL in front f a couple JBS and then
another shot did not go a big reason for the kill
is Cal Peterson look at that right pad redirect
save positioning and then athleticism able to get
across with that right pad and he robs Adrien Kemp
as you can see the frustration on the LA [Music]
Ford